I'm going to share the afternoon session
the first three talks uh that were
invited by the organizers of the um
logic and algorithm and databases in a
program and uh we have three talks here
the first talk is a keynote talk given
by Alon Hali uh Alon has a numerous
number of awards and he's extremely well
known in the database Community but this
is not why not why we invited him here
let me tell you why we invited Al we
invited Al because uh 25 years ago he
was a mainstream database theoretician
publishing uh papers in the top database
Theory conferences but he was not
working on traditional topics he was
working on inovative topics that back
then were Innovative and Visionary data
integration uh localist view globalist
view um query answering using views
these were terms coined by alone uh 25
years ago I we have dozens if not
hundreds of papers studying these these
topics in all possible aspects since
then Alan moved on he moved to Google uh
where he developed some very well-known
systems data um data fusion and
especially web tables same thing here uh
people today are continuing data
exploration and web tables is a
reference system that you need to know
about it so my qu the question on our
mind is what is next what will we be
studying in database Theory know 25
years from now so this is why we have
alone here to get some inspiration so
please take it away thank you Dan um
it's really nice to be in a place where
there are people who knew me since I was
25 I'm looking at you but there are a
bunch of others who knew me in my 20s um
so I'm I I'm not sure I'm going to give
an answer to that question but thank you
for the really kind introduction um I'm
gon to be talking hopefully we'll be I'm
sure we're going to be talking about
this topic in 25 years from now okay I'm
not sure how it uh it relates a little
bit to database Theory as well so I'm
going to be talking about well-being Ai
and you that's actually the title of a
book that I'm uh that I'm writing almost
even as we speak and it's about how we
can build AI technology that really
improves our well-being so this is about
a journey that is 1% uh done and so
we're we're thinking about how the
future of this is going to look like
okay um so if if uh we have a ton of
technologies that have been developed uh
for our wellbeing right I mean going
back in history to the to the wheel and
to the light bulb and to the uh you know
Transportation Systems obviously they
improved our well-being but we're focus
more today on on things like digital
technology like uh you know like the
internet and and the phones in your
pockets and uh and for the purpose of
this talk I'm also wearing the meta
Rayband glasses so I can now take a
picture of you and
um there now I can take them off um um
so we're we're the amount of Technology
the amount of things that are measuring
uh what we're doing and knowing what
we're doing is just like
uh expanding uh quite a bit okay so
we're collecting a lot of data about
ourselves now given the new capabilities
of of uh of generative AI we're also
starting to seek conversational
capabilities that are are mind-blowing
okay so so when I was doing AI in grad
school a number of years that we're not
going to we're not going to name if if
you told me that within my lifetime we
will have systems like like gp4 I would
have laughed you out of the room okay so
now we have we have systems that
converse with you they can actually
confidently but every now and
then actually more often than than not
they will tell you things that actually
are true and and uh useful so um so
there are a lot of people in the in the
AI I call it a cacophony of voices right
everywhere you go you hear all kinds of
things about AI there are a lot of
people who are talking about the fact
that in a few years we're going to have
highly personal assistants that are
going to know everything about us are
going to give us advice about everything
we do uh throughout our day whether it's
what to eat what to when to exercise
what relationships to nurture and uh and
and everything like that okay the
problem is right now we're not there we
have a lot of devices we have you know
this thing here is a is an Ura ring it
it knows how well I slept at night but
it doesn't it tell you know it tells me
something very nice in the morning
whether I slept well or not it'll it'll
be nice to me but it doesn't know my
context it doesn't know that maybe I
came back from from Europe and I'm jet
lag and I and I didn't sleep well or
maybe I'm you know I have some stress at
work so it's its advice is completely
out of context of my of my life it
doesn't know me it just knows my sleep
okay so the question is uh can we do
better so over the last few years I've
been really interested in well-being
this is what happens to to retired
database theoreticians
right so uh so I commissioned at some
point when I was uh last time they let
me manage people I uh at megagon I I
paid somebody to create this beautiful
poster about uh happiness okay this was
megagon Labs which is which is still
there we were an AI lab that was trying
to build technology for wellbeing and so
what you see so what you're seeing here
is you know well-being is is um uh
starts with your uh you know your
psychological your financial safety
things like that just so you can you can
get through the day then it it starts
talking about your your your body right
you need to sleep well eat well exercise
all these things but all these things
just prepare you for your mental
well-being okay so you can actually be
uh in the moment when you're trying to
do something um and you can actually
start imagining and start thinking and
you're free to actually uh develop and
then you get higher in the tree um and
this is things more like the the the
meaning in life you're learning you're
creating relationships you're
volunteering you're doing stuff like
that so uh this looks like a little bit
like a beautiful version of of the maslo
uh hierarchy needs even though maslo
never thought about it as a hierarchy
okay so even though this is a tree don't
think of it as as something that you
need to go uh up I mean it doesn't it
doesn't doesn't work that way okay so
the question so so what you're seeing
from this picture is that well-being is
like 5,000 different things right and
and for each one of us it's a very it's
it's an individual combination of all of
these things so what you're seeing in
the industry today is that you have an
app multiple apps for each one of these
right you have one for meditation and
one for dieting and one for exercise one
for sleep and one for this and one for
that and they don't talk to each other
so the question is are we doomed given
wellbeing is such a complicated thing
are we doomed to having 10,000
applications that don't talk to each
other or can we uh or can we do better
than that that's the question that has
been I've been obsessed with for the
last few years okay so here's what I'm
going to do I'm G to argue that um that
that we can't continue going this way
okay so my point is that building that
well-being apps today are a little bit
like what programming used to be before
uh when when we were writing programs
against the hardware okay so so you're
the hardware I'm the hardware okay and
each one of these apps is working
directly towards the hardware and we all
know some of you know I'm too young to
have programmed against the hardware but
um but we all know that doesn't doesn't
work okay and so what we did in computer
science was we came up with this
beautiful thing called operating systems
that is a bunch of components that makes
it easier for programmers to write
programs and for computers to to manage
multiple programs at once right and and
um and it's delightful sometimes uh for
uh for users okay so I'm going to argue
that we need something like an operating
system for well-being in order for us to
be able to build the new generation of
well-being apps in a way that actually
they they the benefits add up rather
than uh they're disjoint from each other
okay um I'm going to talk a little bit
about where I got to from how I got here
so I'm going to talk about human values
some some of the work we did at at meta
and and then halfway through the talk
I'm I'm going to turn back into a
database guy okay so I'm gonna I'm going
to talk about one of the components of
this operating system which is the the
database of you okay your personal
timeline and then I'll I'll pontificate
a little bit about how llms and database
management um are going to some of the
questions that I actually am very
excited about in that realm and I don't
have to get through all the slides so
anytime you have questions uh please
please just stop me if we if we end up
getting into slide four that's fine with
me okay
any questions so
far okay so first of all all the opin if
if you hear an opinion it's mine it's
not my company's my goal is to get
through this talk without getting fired
yes your assumption is that we do need
that
app yes I I so I would love I mean I
would love to have one app that is sort
of an extension of me that just takes
care of everything for me to to a degree
where I'm going to give it I'm going to
I'm going to negotiate with what I what
I delegate to it and what not but yeah I
want I personally I want something that
knows everything about me so it can
actually give me
help but that's that's not everybody
agrees with that okay but but what I'm
arguing is that even if you don't want
that we still need that operating system
so these applications can at least
coordinate at a minimal at a minimal
level question may maybe it's harmful to
you to
stuff we'll get into that okay so so I
should say everything we do in in
especially in Ai and generative AI right
everything we do has um has a good part
and a and a harmful part so we we need
to think about these things from the
very beginning and and um I worked for
meta remember we know about Hearts I
I'll get to this in a minute okay um
okay so so any opinions that you hear
are have nothing to do with my employer
um and and I'm gonna ask many more
questions that I'm going to be able to
answer which hopefully um you guys can
help Okay so uh I I sort of said all
this already okay so we need a a a new
abstraction we need an operating system
for um for wellbeing now when we talk
about a computers we coming up with the
operating system is is easy I hope there
are no OS people in the room here that
will kill me but but you know we built
these system so we know what the
components are with humans right what
what the heck are these components how
can we do this in a way that actually
has a bunch of of of components that are
useful uh for application Builders and
and for your well-being
we have called uh so this is a book that
we're writing uh my co-author uh um
whose name I can't say yet because her
company has not released not uh agreed
yet for us to publish the book but um
you know it's it's a name in there she's
actually a PhD in Psychology okay so
anything I say about well-being is is uh
comes from her we call it OS operating
system well so Oswell that's the
operating system now it does sound a
little bit like Orwell and I know some
of you are already thinking about Big
Brother this is a pure pure coincidence
but
I but I think it's a happy coincidence
because because we're we're we're going
to emphasize that it's not Orwell we
this is this is an S not an R okay um
okay so here are the component so so I
can finish my talk right here so these
are the the three components of the
operating system that we see that that
we are proposing okay and and we know
that this is is just an initial proposal
so we're not um but but let's start so
it's experiences attention and and uh
connection let's let's talk about each
one of these so the experiences is the
database of you okay fundamentally the
more the AI knows about you the better
advice you uh it can give you okay so
what what do I mean by know about you I
mean knowing about your past experiences
your subjective experiences about what
about what you had your aspirations for
the future your partially formed plans
for the future we're going to talk more
much more about this in a moment um your
habits your preferences anything that
that factors into how you make decisions
on a daily basis okay and the point here
is that given all the data that we're
already creating we're leaving all these
breadcrumbs all over this you know all
over the clouds right we can actually
create this thing and and and already
create useful uh
useful uh observations from it the
second uh component is attention
Okay your attent your life is your
attention Okay so I I love this story
from Dan Leviton the author of an organ
mind where he met Jimmy Carter when
Jimmy Carter was running for
president 1975 okay and he had a
conversation with Jimmy Carter and Jimmy
Carter was he was really impressed by
the fact that Jimmy Carter was
completely focused on him okay he was
completely present not worried about
anything going on he was focused on on
Dan Levon and he was like how does Jimmy
Carter do this well Jimmy Carter doesn't
do this he's got a hundred other people
that are making sure that at any point
in his day he's attending to the most
important thing and when when Dan
levon's time is up somebody will come
and take Jimmy Carter to to the mo the
next most important thing to do okay so
why can't we all be Jimmy Carter why
can't we all have an assistant that at
any given point in the day at least
tries to help us focus on the most
important thing that we need to do right
now and it doesn't need to be
productivity it could also be just like
playing a video game if we need a rest
or or going for a walk or or spending
some time with our our uh kids and and
and seeing how they're feeling okay so
so attention is your life okay and so so
when you go further into the detail here
there are two things in attention one is
a bunch of recommendation systems that
know a lot about you so they could
recommend what to read what to eat what
to do with your free time uh stuff like
that and planners right we all spend a
lot of time ruminating about all kinds
of details about our life right that
that could be handled by a computer Okay
so we've have recommendation systems and
planners in our attention
component the connection component is um
kind of exciting right I mean we we all
know that that our life is is our
relationships right those are the most
important things we do they're the most
challenging but the most rewarding
things we do in life is is develop and
and nurture relationships um so the the
role of the component relation of the
connection component is to help us
manage that try to understand what with
what do value do we get from each
relationship what value do we bring to
each relationship what what are our
goals with these relationships which
ones need more attention right now which
ones can we put on the back burner for a
bit just help us find uh uh um be be and
do for the for the people in our lives
uh as best as as we can and it's not
just relationships with people it's
relationships with with communities
right so a lot of us our our sense of of
identity is the communities that we
belong to and our the health of those
relationships is um a huge a huge
component to our
wellbeing okay I want to say so so when
I joined meta I joined this team that
that developed machine learning models
for uh protecting
online removing bad content from uh from
the platform okay so hate speech
misinformation bullying uh all that
stuff okay so there there's a list of 50
violations that that Facebook tracks or
at least at the time it track there are
50 bad things that people do okay 50
categories of bad things that people do
and we have we have teams and machine
learning models that try to identify
these things using AI because have a
huge amount of content um uh being
uploaded and it's in different you know
in hundred and something languages in
different cultural Realms and and all
that stuff okay so our team uh so so
there's a huge team and then there's an
AI team that that uh that worked with
them to develop the AI models okay
now so we were trying to enforce the
community policies of uh of Facebook and
every every online platform or social
platform has has their uh their policies
right and but fundamentally we realized
that we were making ethical decisions
right so when you sayl you can't say
this thing on Facebook you're saying
you're limiting Free Speech but you're
you're trading that off against the the
the safety of or the well-being of your
of your audience okay or when we're
saying that we're not going to try to
determine your your ethnicity from uh
from your posts or your or anything that
you do unless you tell us exactly what
your ethnicity is we're not allowed to
actually try to figure out your
ethnicity okay but that trades off our
usefulness right maybe we can find
something that is really really useful
for your specific ethnicity like a a
drug that just came on the market and
and might you know address a certain
population of people but we we can't
give that to you because we're because
we decided not to figure that not to
uh you know figure out your your
ethnicity so there was a lot of interest
in in okay what are the human values
that uh that a a recommendation system
that any any social network should even
be thinking about okay and these these
values are not just about uh about
recommendation systems they're about AI
systems in general we're seeing the same
thing today with with generative AI so
so the answer to the question is is here
so what what uh actually Jonathan stray
from here from Berkeley and I built this
Coalition of 21 people who from all uh
from Academia from industry from policy
and and journalism and law and and uh
even a bunch of AI people and we we
wrote this pretty long paper that was
finally accepted to ACM tourus where we
at least gave the the foundation the
list of of values that we that uh based
on on a lot of our research uh that are
relevant to uh to recommendation systems
and we we describe the state-of-the-art
and and the technical challenges that
are um
uh that have to do with each one of
these values now so if you're looking
for a great research topic or a PhD
thesis for students that just read this
paper in section five you'll find a
bunch okay the point that the one one of
the reasons I'm trying to uh bring up
here is
that as Facebook right I can align with
human values all I want suppose I did
the perfect job right of of uh uh of
aligning with with Facebook but
hopefully you don't spend more than 5%
of your day on Facebook okay even less
than that I mean I would thank you as a
stockholder but you probably don't okay
and so so what's the point right of of
of uh of trying to you know completely
align with human values if my effect on
your day right is is is is minimal so in
order to really affect your well-being
we need to have a much uh more holistic
view of everything that you do or
everything that you engage with either
online or hopefully in the real world in
order to to meaningfully uh address or
improve your well-being so that's
how that's how I got to this okay any
questions far Okay so so we're going to
talk about
experiences okay so so let's so now now
I'm turning into a database guy okay so
I'm going to slow down a little
bit okay so let's let's imagine a new
ecosystem or actually an existing
ecosystem of personal Digital Data so
today you are leaving breadcrumbs
everywhere right every time I go for a
run this thing knows it this thing knows
how I sleep uh Amazon knows what I buy
Spotify knows that I listen to to Lex
Freedman too much everything I do is
most things that I do are are are known
somewhere in the digital realm okay so I
can create um and I and I have I'll show
you in a second I can actually create a
what we call a personal timeline that
has all my digitally recorded
experiences okay and I we did this okay
it's it's it's big okay and over this
now as a database guy right the first
thing I'm going to I want to do is query
this thing right when where did I go
running when I was in intell or um you
know what was that name of the
restaurant I went to on my second night
in Tokyo stuff like that okay so this
thing is like the the transactional
database of my life okay everything I
did is going to be in there that's
that's great but but there are things
that you can do that we know from from
database World which is you can go and
and start creating views right so out of
this thing you can start creating
summaries of yourself okay so you can
you can actually create your your your
food summary your prefer which are
evident from a lot of what you did your
reading preferences your your travel
preferences your exercise routines you
can actually create small summaries of
you that are based on what you've
actually done in life okay now these
things are pretty small you can actually
take them and and and throw them as
context into a chat GPT and start
getting much better answers for your
questions because now the thing is going
to know you okay so we have this this
ability to collect all the data put it
into a a timeline analyze this this uh
this timeline and start creating things
that you can you can go and and uh use
in the in in the real world yeah it
feels like this is a more detailed like
daily like daily diary we can get I just
wonder whether it's whether there is
actually any AD summarize all the and
really show you
dashb just
I'll show you in two slides
okay so um just just hang on for for two
more minutes okay so you so thanks to a
bunch of Europeans okay gdpr enables us
to do this right so according to gdpr
with all the you know jokes that we have
about gdpr you can actually go and
download all your personal data it's a
little clunky now okay but the Europeans
are working for us they're gonna the dma
act the data markets Act is saying that
all this data should be available uh
through an API as well so you're not
going to have to go and download this
thing so you can so you can actually
today download this data and and I
actually did this last year I I sat
there and and I I built this thing but
um and and you don't actually have to
import all the data so if I'm I don't
have to import all my photos all I need
to do is get the captions of the photos
and and you know the most important
things there so it's not going to be a
huge uh necessarily a huge thing when we
get to things like these guys the smart
glasses right you don't even have enough
memory to to store the video your entire
day so we're going to have to learn how
to forget more than uh that's going to
be our our bigger problem uh soon okay
so we did this and uh you can go on on
GitHub and and find it so uh we call it
personal whatever it's a timeline
Builder we just released this a few
months ago and this is this is my
dashboard so this is my April 15th of
2019 um I was attending the Ted
conference so I started by going going
for a run in the morning at Ted they
have espresso machines everywhere so I
was pulling an espresso shot and then
there was a party and whatever okay um
so this is the summary of my day and
believe me there were more interesting
days than this I mean you can it's
actually really interesting to look at
at the hour by hour things of uh that
you did and and um there's so some of
you might remember uh Gordon Bell okay
25 years ago at Microsoft research he
built he and his team built a system
called uh my life bits which imagine
doing this with the technology of 25
years ago okay that talk about being
ahead of your time okay this guy was
ahead of time um and he then wrote a few
years later this book called total
recall that the whole book is talking
about what you can do if you had a
timeline like this okay and and um uh
the possibilities are are are quite
quite impressive in terms of like the
database thing okay um let me know when
I have how I'm doing on time because 20
minutes 20 minutes okay good so so the
join here is very easy okay sorry talked
about joints before but the the the you
have a time you have a time Point okay
you have a time stamp on every
everything you import so so the join is
easy you just put it on a timeline and
you can see everything okay now there's
a question I get question I don't get
this question from database people
because because because we're too smart
but I get question from other people
like why do you need to fuse the data
okay why can't you just like uh talk you
know talk to each each data source by
itself the point is that that the only
way to to really get a a complete
picture of you right is to to look at
everything right so when I go to Tokyo
okay I don't tell my system I'm going to
Tokyo for five days and this is what I'm
doing you I go there I start taking
photos I start navigating to a bunch of
sui Sushi Shops and and using my credit
card right maybe I'm going for a run
around you know in Tokyo that's what you
have you have the raw data right and so
you need to integrate all of that to
figure out that actually the guy is is
uh is is in Tokyo and and and having a
pretty good time right moreover when I
come back I don't land that SFO and I
take a photo of of SFO and say hey I'm
back no the only way you know I'm back
is because because you know the next
morning I went for a run in Los Altos
and you figure out I'm I'm back okay so
so you in order to really get a full
picture of yourself you really need to
fuse um uh data from multiple multiple
sources I mean I read books from like
four different sources right we all I
read books from my library from audible
from from Kindle sometimes I actually go
and buy books right so uh if you want to
get a a good idea of my reading uh you
know profile you got to integrate all
this data yes EX is illegal huh you
don't show any illegal
activities not to get
fired a question what happens to those
they get logged
to they do get logged
um elaborate on this a little
bit can find out unpleasant things so
okay so there there there are uh there
are two issues here one is if you're
doing something illegal
don't record it okay um a little a
little bit of Common Sense okay um
huh I think you can always turn off all
your devices right I mean if if you're
going to kill somebody turn off your
cell phone okay
it's um but but but I think that maybe
the more the more uh Troublesome point
right is you're not doing anything
illegal but maybe the government will
will look at your data and and not like
the kinds of of things that you're doing
right right so there is an issue well
we'll get to privacy in a second here
but there is an issue of privacy here
and and I want to be very clear that
this is we're not we're not completely
throwing
gar conspiracy the here right it's on
preparation of US Government introducing
social credit system like in
China in China they they right they at
the cake so your health insurance
will
that is true so so we'll so I think let
me just say the thing about privacy now
just one sec today I mean so depends
what you mean by privacy okay you can
actually have all this data on your on
your device encrypted okay it's not
actually the the the let me say two
things first of all a lot of the data
that that is coming into the timeline is
already sitting somewhere in the cloud
okay so you're already trusting a bunch
of companies and a bunch of systems to
to to store it for you what happens is
when you start fusing data then the um
you know then the value of it goes up
right nobody wants you know the IRS
fortunately all all data integration
prog projects at the IRS failed right
otherwise we we'd all be in trouble here
right so not not all some of you pay
taxes okay I do too but but the point is
right so it's when when you integrate
data then the value that you can extract
from that is much more but I but you can
actually today I think you can you can
actually store all the integrated data
on your device device if you want
encrypt it and then the question is is
that enough privacy for you or not right
and it sort of depends on your uh your
trust in government and stuff like
that I just going to comment that when I
was a young inia I had all my devices
turned
off yeah mostly because you didn't have
any
right would you define wellbeing and
does it means individual wellbeing
societal well-being
National wellbeing what how do you
define this great question do you have a
few hours uh so
so there are much smarter people than me
to to answer this question this is more
focused on on on individual well-being
but you also have to realize that first
of all In some cultures indiv even
individual well-being right has more to
do with the uh with the well-being of
the society that you're in right so for
example to over simplify in eastern
cultures the society is is actually uh
at least as important if not more
important than the individual so so the
idea the point here is you got to design
the system and the choices that it gives
you in a way that enables you to decide
what values are are most important to
you okay um that's my short answer but
probably yeah so like in this like in
this flow you were kind of going after
different apps to collect this right but
all of these are getting recorded from
different senses on your brain already
are are you also thinking about some
other more efficient way to pull this
out from brain directly know so the
elephant in the room is is the brain
computer interfaces right um I was
actually talking to an expert uh at meta
about brain computer interface just
yesterday and I don't think that's going
to happen anytime soon okay things yeah
yeah so first of all if if you want want
to maintain the Integrity of your skull
then then the stuff that you can extract
from your brain is is limited but even
uh you know with eg devices right you
can you can extract certain signals from
your brain like surprise or what they do
is they they figure out what signals
you're sending down to your motor
neurons so they know that what what key
you're gonna you're about to press right
or what so that's useful because then
you can actually do stuff just by
thinking about it but but but today at
least I haven't heard of any brain
computer interface uh people that
believe that you can actually understand
the concepts or or or thoughts
neuroscientists don't even think there
is such a thing as a
thought yeah confus about when you said
we could integrate everything on our own
device equip it and so on what is them
the financial incentive to provide this
to user like if you cannot sell ads
based on this why would you what's the
incentive of a company to provide this
to um great question and I realize this
is industry day so I need to provide a
business case but but
um I think I think if the if
the if the value is high people will pay
for it okay uh that's one and I um
there's a bigger question which is to
get all that information flow right
today it's very clunky so in order to to
actually be able to bring all that
information into um into one place the
big companies like the Googles and
Amazon and and all that they need to
they need to do some work they need to
decide that it's uh they're going to
support the right API so you can
actually create this um this personal
timeline now uh I think there's a lot in
this for the uh for the big companies
because once you create this new
abstraction once there is such a thing
as a personal database you're GNA have a
huge wave of innovation of apps that can
be built on this and whenever there's a
huge age of W uh wave of Innovations
then the Googles and the Amazon and the
metas of the world will will benefit
okay people pay for currently people pay
for social networks for their own data
they pay for subscriptions to social
networks they don't but would you pay
would you pay five bucks a month to have
a
shrink yeah a psych psychiatrist sorry a
psychologist somebody who you could talk
to all the time Oh you mean an AI an AI
psychologist yes but on on one's own
device well the model of the
psychologist will will be downloaded and
and it'll talk to
you
that it's a good question okay I right
we're not doing anything of this yet
right and so but but but once there are
useful tools there there will be ways of
uh of paying for it I'm I have no doubt
that that the world will find ways of
making money out of
this there are people who there are
companies that make
bices for what therapist AI therapists
okay but hosted on individual devices
I don't I don't know if it's on
device but so the vision of you is that
everybody's complete in control that
means you download it on your device
that's secure and you can then decide
what you give up and people pay for
services downloaded on their own device
that's division that kind of circumvents
the issue of privacy
that so so there there are a bunch of
choices here I'm not I'm not giving the
full this is not a product uh road map
yet okay so there's there's a lot of
work to be done the Privacy thing is by
default all the data is yours and
available only to you okay no no no
questions asked when you want to use the
data for something okay so let's let's
take an example I might go into a
Japanese restaurant okay I love Japanese
food but I don't remember the names of
of what you know of the food items there
okay so I may talk to an agent in the
Japanese restaurant and say share with
this agent all my preferences and
experiences in Japanese rep restaurants
so far for the next 30 seconds okay so
it can give me a recommendation from
their
menu no data leakage no no the the agent
works with me and and that's it okay so
I'm specifying at the moment that I need
a service exactly what to share and I'm
and I'm specifying this in in in natural
language okay now the restaurant to
answer your question okay the restaurant
might say you know we're a very Savvy
Data Mining Restaurant if you will give
us your data for the next 30 days we
will give you a
$10 off your
okonomiyaki fine I just you know
whatever for me that that works out okay
so so so now your data is under your
control and you can actually start
making money off of it if it's if it's
valuable to
others could you comment on the sort of
the reality versus like theoretical U
sort of of data sharing so for instance
I mean ftech like open banking has been
standard in the EU didn't land all the
lobbies and all the things similarly the
whole uh push towards data
interoperability translated to at an FTC
level data transfer across wall Gardens
rather than truly opening it up and
helping individuals get that for free on
their own devices so yeah I'm just
curious as in what is sort of uh at
least in your U from your Vantage Point
what's s the approximate timeline when
something like this will become low
friction in terms of
um I don't have a great answer okay I
mean I think it's it's a matter of of as
a society um uh deciding to do this okay
and and having enough uh enough proofs
of concept and value that that are
demonstrating by doing this uh early on
okay
um now your point that that you know the
the data transformation things sort of
worked in very limited uh Industries
right like Banks can talk to each other
and stuff like that um and that that's
fine because the value was there right
and and Banks really need this right now
we're talking about personal data right
so so it doesn't um the the schema right
you in order to exchange money between
Banks you you need a very very detailed
schema here you're not going to have a
schema your your schema is maybe time
location that's it because because the
variety of things that we do is so vast
that that even trying to generate a
schema is is
useless how five minutes five minutes
okay okay any other questions yes I just
curious I uh just to to get to like the
FAS round of this say existing what what
are the main technology are there any
like hardcore technological challenges
that you see any hard computational
problems or is this just something more
funding and interested to my my next few
slides will partially answer that okay
um okay so so I already alluded to this
a little bit um right now the the the
timeline captures only objective data
about your past right because that's all
that you're storing in in in the cloud
right but actually getting your
subjective experiences of what you
thought for example you were talking to
a friend how did you feel about that
conversation is there something that you
want to remember about this friend so
next time you see them you you can you
could follow up on it um so these things
are are what we typically think of as
journaling and very very very few people
Journal some do um and but I think here
there's actually a potential that with
language models you language models can
start asking you questions that are
specific to what you the experiences
that you've had today so imagine an
agent that sort of knows when you're uh
when you have a few minutes to talk
right maybe you're you're commuting or
you're washing dishes or something like
that um at that point it it knows what
you did during the day and can say well
what did you think about the
conversation that you just had you know
with this person or that person or how
did you like your luncher or stuff like
that so I think there's a um there's an
opportunity to capture much more of our
of our subjective uh experiences but
let's get to um we covered privacy right
so the first problem that any database
person goes to is querying these things
right so if you have a if you have a a
timeline um how are you going to query
this and the second second thing in
database Theory X the set database does
is creates a a taxonomy of queries right
so here the taxonomy is atomic queries
are ones that uh can pretty much be
answered by one item in this uh database
of of of episodes okay so for example
what was the name of the plammer that I
used last month there's probably one
episode uh in in your in your personal
timeline that will get you the answer
okay but things get more interesting
when you when you look at you know where
did I take my mom when she came to visit
or how many times did I go to Singapore
uh stuff like that or tell me that my my
running speed has not slowed down that
much uh in the last 10 years right so
first of all uh we have a synthetic
timeline that we built and uh it appears
in ACL this year wank Chuan who's well
known here um and a bunch of us have um
build it so we can now at least try to
make progress on this um on this agenda
I think so so for the most part I think
you know retrieval augmented uh
generation can pretty much take care of
this not perfect but but probably
advances in that will work well here is
where we need uh database expertise and
so the the point that I'm going to try
so there there are two approaches to
this okay I'll just make this point and
then I'll I'll conclude there's What's
called the llm Fanboy which we have a
lot of them I didn't make up this name
the name was made up by by a boy who's
an llm fan okay um not a boy he's a he's
a he's a 10 year Professor but the point
is that these people think that if you
just wait long enough to GPT n plus one
you can give it anything and and just
like your database go person just just
chill okay your your work on this Earth
is done and and lenss will take care of
everything okay um I don't think that's
quite going to work um the other
approach is the database query
processing Enthusiast okay so here's my
point if you can so so let's look at
this query where where did I take my mom
when she was in Seattle and I can you
know have a bunch of English sentences
saying mom came to Seattle on April 16th
we went to the zoo we did this the the
stock market crashed on April 20th but
Mom I took her to the airport on 23rd
the llm can pretty much figure figure
out what what happened here okay it can
ignore the stock market we're not going
to blame mom for for you know crashing
the stock market but uh but it'll tell
you all the places that we went and and
to a some extent it'll reason about time
and and and space okay the the point
here is to get to get the relevant set
of facts um to the llm so it can
actually do its reasoning and it it can
work with a few more um you know
irrelevant facts but but if you give it
the right facts it'll do it'll do the
right thing which is huge right because
this means we don't need a scheme
anymore this this is like this is for
database people this is like maturity
plus plus right so we can actually do
things over text or images and and this
is this is
awesome however they llms and and and
NLP the NLP ethos doesn't think about
set-based reasoning the way we do as
database people we us databased people
we get up in the morning and we're doing
joints and projections and aggregation
and stuff like that's what we do okay LM
then LP people just think about that
okay so if you're going to ask me how
many times I I went to Japan you have to
take my my timeline you have to
partition it you have to go to a bunch
of places get a bunch of answers from
from from each you know partition and
then start doing unions and Counting and
stuff like that and and you can you can
quote me on this I don't think this is
going to happen in llm land anytime soon
they just don't respect state-based
reasoning the way the way we do in in
the database World okay um we we sort of
made it started this with neural
databases a couple coup years ago at
meta which I'll just point you to the
papers and I will I think I'm I'm out of
I can talk about data integration but
oops Yeah okay I'm done
thanks so maybe uh one more
question yes please eron so I think I
followed the last Parts about the
getting all the data together and the
challenges with the discussion we have
but I'm thinking of the examples you
gave in the beginning
with the triangle and thinking of
attention and making the recommendation
and and there my question is is the
psychology kind of clear enough that
it's even clear what to go after and
what
the like like one thing to describe
someone's situation and describe what
someone's done but then to think of the
consequences of the
recommendation I'm wondering how clear
that
even um
yeah um it depends on the kind of
recommendation you're making
right so for example if you're going to
recommend books to me it's really good
idea that you've seen all the books that
I've ever read okay now even then I can
tell you um I want to go outside of my
comfort zone or I want to stay in my
comfort zone so so you have a lever
there that you can work with now if
you're recommending uh you know I'm I'm
trying to find you know I'm feeling uh
sad and I want to spend that time with a
friend who will Who will just like
listen to me and and make me food okay
um you know the computer can be better
at going through your previous
experiences and saying you know here are
a bunch of people who can do this they
actually live in the area or whatever
right and and I at that point I think
the computer can do a better job at
least in terms of recall so I can make
the the final determination who to call
so I think my philosophy is let the
computer do what what it's good at which
is remember a lot of stuff and compute
fast and then give me the the final the
final say in what in what to do thanks I
think that answered thank you okay
that's order time we have so let let's
thank Al on on once
again and our next speaker uh second
speaker